alleine hätten wir heute ist zu einem
neuen video ist für mich allein sondern
gemacht und innigkeit challenge von
unsere wartet jemand im kern ausschnitt
der und gedacht es eigentlich ganz neu
ist die idee und deswegen werde ich mich
jetzt von den herren setzten ab mittwoch
fragen stellen drei minuten lange danach
zwischen mir und ich werde max beim
tragen und dann schauen wir am ende
beschnitten wer öfter das worden ja nein
nicht oder er gesagt hat weil das in die
vier wörter die wir bei der beantwortung
der fragen die mich nennen dürfen wir
verlieren erachten ein wunderschön doch
klar
mit zitronensaft trinken also ich meine
wurden anreiz da sein
investiert die auf den fragen stuhl und
ihr findet jetzt schon hier unten ein
paar eingebildete find ich würde sagen
es geht wollte 32 ein super du bist ja
warum hast du hast angefangen windows zu
benutzen weil ich auch mutter geld
aufnehmen kann
für mitte dein macbook air oder einsame
definitiv fakt für wie war die
umstellung für ihn springt schwierig das
anstrengend zu anstrengend auch als
feinde richtig die bietet live schwärmt
für die viele sachen überleben schau
nicht mehr weil ich ein erstes
westliches land hängen wollte aber das
geht nicht in der verkappten an die wand
also ist alles gut läuft
würdest du wenn du verlierst kommst du
musst also definitiv oft kommt kommt mit
den vertretern definitiven ok hoffe dass
wenn du was falsches bringen möchte das
bestrafen
ich habe noch was da von sich
die gc-abwehr gewerbeeinheit welche
pisten kanal für eine million abend
wie mache ich war immer mehr brände 132
1 fertig bei der polka sagt mit fragen
[Musik]
ich bin dran deuten wir schauen noch
letzte fragen über den teppich 543 frei
ein gutes feld für abflüsse erstes dabei
dafür die major league könnte ich mir
durchaus vorstellen durch haben sich
gefreut mit 100 helfer ist da schon
[Musik]
hunderte bringen glaubt er nicht hat
seine arbeit einfach kein held aber ich
kann ja auch durch heike friedrich
langen teil waren die bedenken über war
indirekt gefundenen dem wasser stand er
direkt in eine zitrone
die marktakteure liebe gerne einfach mal
an seitenhalt
die anleitungen denken hat er ja nicht
gerecht ich bin auch nicht dabei die
handykarte noch mal gehört machen
[Musik]
davon bin ich schlichtweg diese sehr
schlecht was die steigerung war sehr
schlecht supermarkt oder 50 und eine
letzte frage sagen mir wenn die auch
nicht jahre wird beide gegenseitig bei
minuten lang fragen gestellt und wir
werden hier die datei auf dem gerät und
mal kurz schauen werden sie auch das
wort ja nein nicht so daher gesagt hat
unseren den gleichen auswertungen wieder
ein paar sekunden später endet einfach
passiert war so noch nie passiert man
verwende
ich denke an das volk
kommen bekommt wir haben beide jeweils
die wörter die fünf mal gesagt wir sind
kleidung wird bewegen werden wir beide
einen short trinken oder stolberg
vielmehr die achseln und trotzdem meine
augen wird gerade recht übel wählt einen
live
da das wir profitieren beide davon
herren wenn euch das ganze gemeinderat
lassen leider wer jetzt noch mal den
ball dann schreibt mahlzeiten in die
kommentare und dann sehen wir ja wie
viele leute das von euch nochmal sehen
wollen wir die jungen weil die
eingebettet da könnte man kanal ab und
außerdem findet ihr dort einen schock
eingeblendet hier regen irgendein
anderes video was jetzt aus stecken
könnte außerdem auch mit wachsen
aufgenommen und tecdoc einen kanal der
beschreibung bringen